Transcription: Victor Molineau
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Confinement, limitation des déplacements,
distanciation sociale, reconfinement,
fermeture des frontières,
couvre feu, passe sanitaire.
Cinquième vague.
Je me suis dit que
c’était pile poil le bon moment
pour venir vous parler de voyage.
Si, si, je vous assure, c’est vraiment
la bonne période pour parler de voyage.
Et à ce propos,
je vais vous poser une question.
Lorsque je vous dis le mot voyage,
quelles sont les premières images
qui vous viennent à l’esprit
et dans quel lieu se situent ces images ?
OK, alors ceux qui se sont
projetés à l’étranger,
est-ce que vous pouvez lever
la main, s’il vous plaît ?
OK, et maintenant,
ceux qui se sont projetés en France,
est-ce que vous pouvez lever la main ?
OK, donc, la plupart d’entre nous
associent le voyage au lointain.
Alors, peut-être que
vous n’en pouvez plus de ce Covid,
que vous rêvez de vous évader
et de partir loin.
Eh bien justement, cet après-midi,
nous allons partir loin.
Et peut-être que vous aussi, dès demain,
vous partirez loin,
juste à côté de chez vous,
car je vous propose aujourd’hui
de modifier notre perception du voyage
et même de déconstruire
la notion de voyage.
Je m’appelle Nicolas et j’ai grandi
sur les bords de Loire,
l’un des plus beaux fleuves du monde.
En fait, LE plus beau fleuve du monde.
Ma passion, c'est le voyage.
Alors, à partir de mes 26 ans,
j’ai commencé à prendre l’avion
pour partir loin.
Et mon engagement, c’est l’écologie.
Je pense profondément
que l’on court à notre perte
si on ne relève pas le défi de l’écologie.
C’est un peu contradictoire, tout ça,
notamment en ce qui concerne
le voyage à l’étranger.
Cette contradiction, elle m’a tellement
tourmenté que j’en ai fait mon métier.
Afin d’allier ma passion
et mon engagement,
je travaille depuis plusieurs années
en tant que coresponsable
d’une maison d’édition
qui propose des guides de voyage engagés
dans une démarche de tourisme durable.
Il y a quelques années,
je ne pouvais concevoir
le plaisir du voyage
que si je partais à l’étranger.
Mais malheureusement tout cela
n’est pas sans conséquence.
Pour préserver les conditions de vie
sur Terre,
c’est-à-dire contenir
le réchauffement climatique
à 1,5 degré d’ici la fin du siècle,
chaque Français
devra émettre, d’ici 2050,
moins de 2 tonnes de CO2 par an,
d’après les scénarios élaborés
par le GIEC.
Et lorsque je prends un vol
aller-retour Paris-Bali,
j’émets 5,5 tonnes de CO2
d’après les calculs
de la Fondation GoodPlanet.
Donc, en prenant cet avion pour Bali,
j’émettrais presque trois fois
l’empreinte carbone
que je devrais consommer
sur toute une année entière.
Plus clairement,
à partir du moment
où je mets le pied dans l’avion,
tous les efforts écologiques que j’ai pu
faire dans l’année s’envolent.
Et c'est le cas de le dire.
Je suis donc dans une sorte
de conflit intérieur
entre mes envies de voyages
et mes valeurs,
ce qui provoque chez moi
une certaine forme de culpabilité.
On appelle ça une dissonance cognitive
et moi, j’appelle ça
la contradiction du voyageur écolo.
Peut-être que certains d’entre vous
ressentent aussi parfois
cette contradiction.
De là, un simple constat s’offre à moi :
le voyage à l’étranger en avion
doit rester exceptionnel.
Et pendant plusieurs années,
ce constat m’a rendu triste.
Il m’a rendu triste parce que
les publicités, les compagnies aériennes,
les réseaux sociaux
nous ont fait croire que
c’était facile de partir loin.
Ils nous ont montré que le bonheur
se trouvait à l’autre bout du monde.
Les vingt endroits à visiter absolument
dans sa vie,
les cent lieux à voir avant de mourir.
Si tu ne veux pas avoir de regrets,
il faut absolument voir
le Machu Picchu, le Taj Mahal,
la tour de Pise,
les temples d’Angkor, tous agglutinés.
Il faut avoir une liste de rêves,
il faut partir toujours plus loin,
aller toujours plus vite.
Il faut découvrir le maximum de choses
possible pour ne rien manquer.
Ne rien regretter.
A tel point que j’en avais parfois oublié
de voir les plaisirs et les beautés
d’à côté.
Et puis tout a changé lorsque
j’ai modifié ma perception du voyage
et je me suis même dit
qu’il fallait que je redéfinisse
le mot voyage.
La définition du mot voyage,
selon le dictionnaire Larousse,
c’est l’action de se rendre dans un lieu
relativement lointain ou étranger.
Et si ce lointain n’était finalement
pas une destination ?
Pourquoi nous prenons
tant de plaisir à voyager ?
Qu’est-ce que nous allons chercher
dans le voyage lointain ?
Nous aimons voyager loin
pour plusieurs raisons.
Par exemple, nous aimons voyager loin
pour s'émerveiller et se dépayser.
Et si pour cela, il n'était pas forcément
nécessaire de partir vers une destination,
mais plutôt de vivre une expérience
remplie de sensations ?
En mars 2020, nous étions
toutes et tous confinés.
Et là, on s’est dit,
bon, chez moi sans pouvoir sortir,
ça va peut-être être un petit
peu difficile de s’évader.
Et puis,
la Ligue pour la protection des oiseaux
a proposé à chacune et chacun d’entre nous
de recenser les oiseaux de nos jardins.
Alors moi, durant de longues heures,
j’étais aux aguets,
à la recherche des oiseaux.
Et je me suis surpris.
Je me suis surpris à ressentir
les mêmes sensations
que lorsque j’étais
à l’autre bout du monde
pour observer les animaux.
Alors oui, je n’ai pas vu de toucans,
mais j’ai ressenti le bonheur infini
lié au fait de guetter,
d’être dans l’incertitude
et de me réjouir
lorsque l’oiseau rare apparaît.
Et finalement, c'est ça le voyage.
Et puis, on a de la chance de pouvoir
se dépayser dans notre propre pays,
puisque la France ne manque pas
de répartie.
Envie de Colorado ?
Voici les ocres de Rustrel,
dans le Vaucluse.
Envie du Sahara ?
Voici la dune du Pilat, en Gironde.
Envie d’un temple au Cambodge ?
Voici le Palais idéal du facteur Cheval
dans la Drôme.
Envie de Cappadoce, en Turquie ?
Voici les Orgues d’Ille-sur-Têt
dans les Pyrénées orientales.
Envie d’une steppe en Mongolie ?
Voici le lac de Nino, en Haute-Corse.
Envie de découvrir le plus
beau fleuve du monde?
Nul n’est censé ignorer la Loire.
(Applaudissements)
Et d’autres fois,
nous souhaitons voyager loin
pour aller à la rencontre
d’autres cultures
et ainsi vivre de nouvelles expériences.
Et si pour cela, il n’était pas forcément
nécessaire de sortir de son pays,
mais plutôt de sortir
de sa zone de confort ?
Il est vrai que dans notre pays,
il est parfois plus difficile
de retrouver cette immersion culturelle
que l’on peut trouver à l’étranger.
Mais on peut trouver une diversité
de personnes, de cultures
et de modes de vie incroyables.
En France, j’ai participé à des
rassemblements de Latino-américains.
J'ai rencontré des chamans.
J’ai passé plusieurs journées
avec des personnes
qui vivent dans des écolieux
en autosuffisance.
J’ai partagé mon quotidien
avec des nomades
et toutes ces personnes
aux modes de vie si différents
m’ont fait découvrir de nouvelles cultures
et de nouvelles façons d’aborder la vie,
tout cela dans mon propre pays.
Et figurez-vous qu’on peut même rencontrer
ces personnes chez soi.
Oui, en accueillant
des voyageurs de passage.
Chez moi, j’ai partagé mon quotidien
avec des Iraniens,
des Lituaniens, un Touareg du Niger...
Et je peux vous dire qu’en restant
sur mon propre canapé,
eh bien je suis parti voyager
très, très, très loin.
Parfois, nous souhaitons aussi
voyager loin
pour aller à la rencontre de nous-mêmes
parce que le voyage est aussi initiatique.
Alors peut-être que,
pour certains d’entre vous,
c’est l’image qui vous vient en tête
lorsque je parle de voyage initiatique.
En tout cas, pour moi, c’est le cas,
donc lorsque je suis allé en Asie,
je suis tout de suite parti dans un temple
en Thaïlande et dans un ashram en Inde.
Et puis, je me suis rendu compte
qu’en France,
ces ashrams et ces temples
sont en fait partout.
On en trouve dans chacun
de nos départements.
Alors, l'été dernier, je suis parti
séjourner dans une bastide en Ardèche
pour pratiquer la méditation dynamique,
une méditation spécifique
à l’ashram d’Osho.
Eh bien, figurez-vous
que les enseignements et les pratiques
étaient exactement les mêmes qu’en Inde.
Durant ces quelques jours,
j’ai voyagé dans mon monde intérieur
et dans le monde invisible.
J’ai voyagé dans mon cœur,
j’ai voyagé dans mon corps.
J’ai voyagé en connexion avec l’humanité.
Et même avec l'univers tout entier.
Oui, je suis parti, mais tellement loin.
D’ailleurs, je suis en train de voyager
dans les pensées
de certaines et certains d’entre vous.
Et certaines de ses pensées me murmurent :
« Mais qu’est ce qu’il raconte, ce garçon,
il est complètement perché ! »
Et j’ai envie de vous dire,
vous aussi, soyez perché.
Laissez-vous porter
par ces voyages intérieurs
et vous verrez qu’en allant juste ici,
vous irez bien plus loin
que dans n’importe quel pays.
Et puis, parfois, nous souhaitons
voyager loin,
simplement pour se reposer
et passer du temps avec ses proches.
Est-ce que pour cela,
on a vraiment besoin
d’aller dans un hôtel all-inclusive
en Tunisie pour aller
se reposer au bord d’une plage ?
Est-ce vraiment nécessaire de prendre
l’avion pour accéder à ce bonheur ?
Alors qu’en Bretagne,
on a de magnifiques plages pour se poser.
Et je vous assure,
il fait parfois très, très
beau en Bretagne.
Bon, peut-être un petit peu moins
que sur les bords de Loire, quand même.
Et enfin, peut-être que certains
d’entre vous aiment voyager loin
pour vivre l'aventure.
Alors moi, l’aventure,
c’est quelque chose d’important.
Je suis parti au Nicaragua,
mon premier voyage lointain.
Je rêvais de sillonner
des terres inconnues
et de me risquer à de nouvelles aventures
et de m’immerger
dans de nouvelles cultures.
Et finalement,
ma grande épopée se résumait souvent
à dormir en auberge de jeunesse
dans des villes touristiques,
à passer mon temps
avec d’autres voyageurs occidentaux
et à manger des pizzas hawaïennes.
Ce qui n'est pas vraiment la spécialité
culinaire du Nicaragua.
Et six ans plus tard, je suis parti
en pleine forêt, sans nourriture.
Je mangeais les plantes
que j’identifiais dans la nature.
J'ai appris à faire du feu.
J’ai dormi à même le sol
sur un tapis de feuilles mortes.
Ça, c'était l'aventure.
J'ai voyagé dans le temps.
À l'époque des chasseurs cueilleurs.
Et figurez-vous que cette expérience,
eh bien, je l’ai vécue
en forêt d’Orléans,
juste à côté de chez moi,
lors d’un stage de survie et de bushcraft.
Et puis,
quelque temps plus tard,
je suis parti sur la Loire à vélo.
Et sur mon vélo, eh bien,
j’ai goûté à la liberté absolue,
une liberté profonde
que je n’avais jamais ressentie
auparavant.
Alors oui, je suis heureux,
heureux de pouvoir vivre ma passion
accessible, juste à côté,
sans besoin de beaucoup de temps,
de beaucoup d’argent
et tout en étant en accord
avec mes valeurs écologiques.
Et j’ai envie de vous partager,
cet après-midi, trois idées
pour ressentir ces plaisirs du voyage
près de chez soi.
La première idée,
c’est bien sûr
de réenchanter la proximité,
de déconstruire ce mythe tout puissant
qui nous dit que le voyage et l’aventure
sont synonymes de contrées éloignées
ou, en d’autres termes, que
l’herbe est toujours plus verte ailleurs.
Regardons à nouveau cette herbe
qui est sous nos pieds
et retrouvons de l’exotisme
près de chez nous.
La seconde idée, c’est d’aller chercher
les plaisirs du voyage dans la simplicité,
la lenteur et la sobriété.
Souvent, lorsqu’on pense
à son prochain voyage,
on se dit OK, alors là,
j’ai trois semaines de vacances,
je vais en Ardèche ou en Corse.
Je regarde, alors là bas, il y a ça, ça,
ça, ça, ça et ça à voir.
OK, donc, il faut
que je m’organise au mieux
pour découvrir
le maximum de choses possibles.
On se crée une liste de choses
à faire, comme au travail.
D’ailleurs, on dit souvent,
« J’ai fait l’Ardèche »
ou « j’ai fait la Corse ».
Et puis, on se rend compte que finalement,
découvrir les dix choses à voir absolument
ne nous rendent pas forcément
plus heureux.
Et à l'inverse de tout cela, on peut
pratiquer le slow tourisme.
Plutôt que de voyager plus pour voir plus,
l’idée est de ne pas tout voir
pour mieux le voir.
S’imprégner d’un lieu,
se reconnecter à la nature.
Prendre le temps
de discuter avec les habitants,
se laisser porter par les imprévus
et surtout ne pas avoir trop d’attentes.
Et enfin, la dernière idée,
c’est d’aller chercher des expériences
plutôt que des destinations.
Là encore, souvent,
lorsqu’on pense à son prochain voyage,
on se dit,
où est-ce que j’ai envie d’aller ?
Plutôt logique.
Et si on se demandait plutôt,
quelles expériences j’ai envie de vivre ?
Et ça, ça change totalement
notre façon d’aborder le voyage.
Parce que en se posant cette question,
c’est l’expérience qui nous amène
à la destination, et non l’inverse.
Et l’avantage,
en allant chercher des expériences,
c’est qu’on se rend compte que
tout ce que l’on souhaite profondément
est souvent accessible
dans notre propre pays.
La définition du mot voyage,
c’est l’action de se rendre dans un lieu
relativement lointain ou étranger.
Et si l’époque que nous vivons
était finalement l’occasion
de redéfinir ce lointain ?
Si le lointain n’est pas une destination,
mais une expérience
emplie de sensations ?
Si le lointain ne consiste pas
à sortir de son pays,
mais à sortir de sa zone de confort ?
Si le lointain n’est pas un voyage
au delà de nos frontières,
mais un voyage intérieur
au plus profond de nous-mêmes ?
Si le lointain n’est pas
une terre inconnue,
mais la liberté d’une simple aventure ?
Alors, il n’existe plus aucune frontière
pour le voyage et l’aventure,
le lointain est partout autour de nous.
Il suffit juste d’aller le chercher
pour ainsi ressentir
les plaisirs du voyage près de chez soi,
tout en contribuant à préserver la nature,
le vivant et les générations futures.
Alors, je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous
de très beaux voyages lointains
juste à côté de chez vous.